[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا الكرام انا طاهر بركه
احييكم وانا راويه القاسم هذه العربيه
موازنه وايران الجديده اغداقا على
المؤسسات العسكريه والدينيه والاعلاميه
وتجاهل لاوجاع الاقتصاد
تركي اودى بحياته ثلاثه من ضباطه الاسد
يشترط ان يكون انهاء ما وصفه بالاحتلال
التركي اساسا لاي لقاء
وتتابعون معنا الليله ايضا
اسماء الوثائق تطارد بعد ترامب وزاره
العدل تعين مدعيا خاصه لتحقيق وترامب
يترقبوا لاصطياد المكاسب
البدايه من ملف الحرب الاوكرانيه ففي
تقرير لا يتكرر كثيرا اكدت صحيفه ولسترين
جورنال تكبر القوات المسلحه الاوكرانيه
خسائر فادحه في المعارك قرب ضخمه
القوات المسلحه الاوكرانيه الموجوده قرب
بخموت انا خسائر اوكرانيا تفوق خسائر
الروس وارجح القائد الاوكراني امكانيه
التراجعي في حال استمرار الوضع على حاله
الاوكرانيه لبخمود والانتقال لخطي دفاعا
جديد على خلفيه الخسائر التي تكبدتها
القوه الاوكرانيه مؤخرا
لكن القصه في مخنوقه راويه كما تابعنا على
مدار الايام الماضيه تبدا من سوليدار
فسيطرت روسيا على البلده باتت قريبه بحكم
التطورات الميدانيه على ارض الواقع حتى
وان اجل الصمود الاوكراني الحزم شبكه سي
ان ان نقلت رساله نصيه عن جندي اوكراني في
سوليدار اوضح فيها ان الجنود الروس يشوشون
على الاتصالات الاوكرانيه وان الامر يزداد
سوءا في ظل عدم وجود قاده عسكريين
اوكرانيين بالمنطقه نائبه وزير الدفاع
الاوكرانيه هانما مليار اقرت بان الوضع في
البلده صعب في ظل معاركه هي الاعنف مع
القوه الروسيه واضافت ان القوات
الاوكرانيه تقاتل دون توقفا رغما شراسه
المعركه
ما تزالوا المعارك العنيفه مستمره في
سوليدار بمنطقه باخموت على الرغم من الوضع
الصعب يقاتل الجنود الاوكرانيون بضراوى
العدو الذي يحاول دون جدوى اختراق دفاعنا
والقبض على سوليداره تعاني القوه الروسيه
من خسائر فادحه وتوجد جثثهم داخل المدينه
بتقديم الدعم العسكري لاوكرانيا حيث اعرضت
بولندا عن استعدادها لان تزود اكياف
باربعه 10 دبابه ثقيله متطوره من نوع
ليوبارد تو على ان يحصل ذلك في اطار تحالف
دولي يجري العمل حاليا على بنائه بدورها
اعلنت ليتوانيا انها سترسل الى اوكرانيا
انظمه مضاده للطائرات من نوع زانهتها
[موسيقى]
هذا التقدم الروسي في دمياط لم يكن بايدي
الجيش وحده بل بسبب الجهود الاكبر التي
كانت لقوات الروسيه الخاصه
ليبدو وان الضوء الاخضر
في القياده العسكريه الروسيه لم يكن
متوقعا من قوه عسكريه كبرى عاشت على امجاد
الجيش الاحمر الخبر الاهم كان استبدال
روسيا من جديد لقائد قواتها في اوكرانيا
لتعين هذه المره الجنرال فاليري جرسيموف
رئيس اركان القوات المسلحه قائدا للعمليه
هناك
واكدت الوزاره في بيان ان جراسيموف عين
قائدا لمجموعه القوات المشتركه المنتشره
في اوكرانيا بديلا عن سرجي» الذي تولى
المنصب لمده ثلاثه اشهر وبالكات الدفاع
الروسيه اوضحت ان رفع مستوى قياده العمليه
الخاصه في اوكرانيا مرتبط بزياده المهام
التي يتعين انجازها والحاجه الى تفاعل
اوثق بين مكونات القوات المسلحه بحسب بيان
للجيش الروسي راويه اذا طاهر الوضع الان
في القياده العسكريه الروسيه للعمليات
سيكون تحت امراض فاليريجي راسي قائدا لها
فيما سيتولى الجنرالات سرقه سورفيكين
واوليج سيليكونوف والكسيكيم مساعداته لكن
نعود مره اخرى الى اسم سورفيكين هذا
القائد السابق
للعمليات الذي عين في اكتوبر الماضي
لاصلاح وضع الجيش الروسي الذي تكبد
انتكاسات في منطقتي خاركا وخرسون
ونظم سرقه سورفيكين انسحاب القوات الروسيه
من مدينه خرسون في مطلع نوفمبر والذي وصف
بانه نكسه كبيره
هذه المده الزمنيه القصيره سلطه الضوء على
تناقضا تناقض لحلفاء الرئيس افلامير بوتن
مع بعضهم البعض بشان التقدم في ساحه
المعركه وهو ما وثقته صحيفه نيويورك تايمز
عبر شهادات من خبراء ومدوني حرب موالينا
للكرمنت اكدوا فيها ان التغيير بعيد كل
البعد عن الاصلاح الجذري الذي يحتاجه
الجيش الروسي ليصبح اكثر فعليا التقرير
افاد بان التغيير اظهره ان بوتن مازال
يركز على الحفاظ على توازن القوى بين
الحلفاء الرئيسيين بدلا من تصحيح العيوب
الاساسيه للجيش ليبقى السؤال الاهم هل
سيكون القائد الجديد فالريج راسي موف
كسابقيه والمساله مجرد تغيير اسماء دون
خططه جواهر
[موسيقى]
صحيفه التلغراف اهتمت بموضوع التغيير
السريع للقيادات العسكريه الروسيه
والسعانات بخبراء لتحليل ما يسميه الغرب
مبدا جراسمه الذي يرى ان الانتصار في
الحروب لا يتم في ساحه المعركه فقط بلبل
حرب السيبراني ايضا الا انا العديد من
الاسئله التي يواجهها بوتن في الحرب ستبقى
عالقه رغم تغيير القيادات حسب الصحيفه
فالجينيرالات الروس لا يستطيعون تغيير
قواعد اللعبه او اسكات المنتقدين بمن فيهم
رئيس مجموعه
الذي تتصاعد دعواته لمحاسبه المسؤولين عن
تعثر الجيش في عمليته خلال العام باكرانيا
تاتي هذه التطورات فيما يدور الحديث في
اروقه الاستخبارات الغربيه عن تعبئه جديده
في روسيا عبد الجواد الرشد والتفاصيل
مخاوف اعلان موجه جديده لتعبئه في روسيا
لا تزال قائمه بين الشباب الروسي على
الرغم من تعبئه 320,000 جنديا روسي خلال
الموجه الاولى وسط تقارير اعلاميه وغربيه
تتحدث عن امكانيه بدء عمليه التعبئه بعد
انتهاء اعياد راس السنه في روسيا وفي ظل
عدم وجود ضمانات لعدم اعلانها بسبب عدم
بتوقيع الرئيس الروسي على مرسومه ينهيها
اما الكرنب اكد على عدم صحتها هذه
الشائعات وشدد على ضروره الاستماع فقط الى
التصريحات الرسميه وفي ظل خطط وزير الدفاع
الروسيس الجيش ارجوك زياده حجم الجيش الى
مليون و500 شخص تحدث رئيس لجنه الدفاع في
مجلس الدومه عن امكانيه زياده سن التجنيد
في روسيا الى 30 عاما
اذا ناقصه في هذا الخطا اسامينا كاتيا طعم
من هذه الرساله ههه
كان هذا هو الجديد في ما يتعلق بالقياده
والتعبئه في روسيا لكن الوضع على الارض
يطلعون عليه الان من دنياتك مراسل العربيه
رائد الاخضر اهلا بك معنا رائد ورائد فعلا
معنا اريد ان اعرف منك اولا اخر التطورات
الميدانيه على الارض في المعركتين
الداميتين
الحسيمتين وسوليدار
طاهر مساء الخير لك ولي راويه بالفعل لا
اعلم
[موسيقى]
اذا انفجارات واصوات اطلاق النار من
المدافع والراجمات الصواريخ منذ صباح
الباكر والمعركه ممتده ليست في شمال
دانيسكو انما هنا في قلب المدينه تسقط
القذائف والصواريخ باستمرار لابد ان
القصفه الاوكراني على مدينه كما وصفه
الخبراء هو عمليه انتقاميه للتقدم الروسي
في المحور الشمالي على محور سيلدار بالفعل
اعلن قائد قوات بادنر انه تم تصفيه اكثر
من 500 جندي اوكراني رفضوها الاستسلام وان
السيطره تمت بشكل كامل على مدينه سوليدار
ايضا زعيما الانفصاليا هنا بالنسبه
باكملها تمت السيطره عليها الحديث عن
سوليدار همم رغم ان الدفاع الروسيه هذا ما
كان غريبه ان الدفاع الروسيه في تقريرها
اليومي لم تتطرق الى الحديث عن معارك
سوليدار بس تحدثت عن انجازات القوات
الروسيه في عده محاور فيدانياتسو فيلوغانس
وفي خرسون وفي زاباروجه بالفعل تشهد
المعارك ذروتها في هذه الايام بالفعل عاده
الجيش الروسي للتقدم على خلاف ما شاهدناه
من انسحاب للقوات الروسيه في الاشهر
الماضي كان في دمار او في خرصون بالفعل
اليوم نرى القوات الروسيه والموالي
الروسيه ايضا تتقدم في محور دانيت في
مارينكا عمليات تنظيف ايضا كما هي في
سوليدار في اطرافها في امريكا اقتحاميه
هذه المدن هي متاخمه لمدينه اانيه محمود
الى سوريا طاهر تقول المصادر من هناك بان
المعارك ضاريه ومحترمه في الناحيه الغربيه
واشارات الى وصول امدادات عسكريه للجانب
الاوكراني لتعزيز الخط الدفاعي بينما
يعني
القوات الروسيه تقصد باستمرار بالمدفعيه
وبالصواريخ اي امدادات اي تقصف الطرق
الموصله الى تمركز القوات الاوكرانيه من
محورين باك مط وكذلك اكرامي طرس قصف اليوم
مركز اتصالات الجديد كان يؤمن الاتصال ما
بين المقاتلين على الجبهات وقواعد
العسكريه الاوكرانيه عمليات تنظيم حسب
السلطات المحليه وحسب قواتنا التجري لكن
السيطره كامله على همم محور مدينه سوليدار
وسط الدفاع الروسيه
اليوم تحدثت عن ان القوات الاوكرانيه
تتكبت خسائر فادحه في بخموت انتم كم
مراسلين يعني اللي كان بدهم حتى محمود هل
من معلومات على الارض من القوات التي
تتكبت خسائر اكثر في العتاد والجنود
اذا كان التقدم للقوات الروسيه والسيطره
على الارض للقوات الروسيه فهذا يعني ان
الخاسر او الذي ينسحب هو الذي يتكبر اكبر
خسائر بالفعل هنا تظهر لنا فيديوهات عبر
وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي
لقتلى اوكرانين عمليات قتل
لمقاتلين الاوكرانيين وكذلك تظهر
الفيديوهات سيطره وتقدم بري للقوات
الروسيه في محور سيلدار خاصه
لابد ان الحديث الذي يصدر عن قوات راجنر
او عن قائد همم السلطات المحليه
فيه شيء من الواقع لانه همم الوضع من همم
يعني الذي نسمعه ونرى عبر الفيديوهات يشير
الى تقدم القوات الروسيه وتكبير الاجانب
الاوكراني خسائر كبيره شكرا
رائد الاخضر
هذه التغيرات على مسار العمليه العسكريه
اثق ان القائد الجديد خبير لكن امل ان
يكون قادر على العمل مع الخبراء الاخرين
وسينتهي كل شيء بشكل جيد للجميع
حقيقي
360 ايضا
وزير الطاقه خارجيه فرنسا والمانيا في
اثيوبيا
السلام وتقديم المساعدات
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد اتخذت ازمه المواطن
البريطاني الايراني علي رضا اكبر منحا
جديدا بعد ان اتهمته وكاله الانباء
الرسميه الايرانيه بلاعب دور في اغتيال
العالم الايراني محسن فخري زاده في عام
2020 في غضون ذلك قالت عائله اكبر ان
السلطات الايرانيه تستعد لاعدامه وقالت
زوجه اكبر ان احد المسؤولين طلب منها
الحضور الى سجنه في طهران من اجل لقاء
اخيرا طلبت بريطانيا ايران بوقف تنفيذ حكم
الاعدام بحق اكبر وقالت انه ذو نوافير
سياسيه
وينضم الينا من لندن مراسل العربيه مصطفى
زارو اهلا بك مصطفى يعني اليوم كان هناك
جلسه برلمانيه ببريطانيا تم النقاش فيها
عن ما يحصل
بايران من يعني عنف بحق المتظاهرين
وخرجت الخارجيه بتصريح رسمي لتقول بان
بريطانيا تدرس تصنيف الحرس الثوري
الايراني بقائمه الارهاب ارتباط ذلك بقضيه
علي رضا اكبر
ابدا اولا من الشق الاول من سؤالك جلسه
مناقشه امتدت لثلاث ساعات تقريبا وعشر
دقائق كلها تطرقت الى الوضع في ايران
بالاضافه الى قمع السلطات المحتاجين طولك
كل هذه الفتره وايضا تم تلاوه اسماء التي
تم اعدامهم بالاضافه الى اسماء اخرى في
السجن او تنتظر الاعدام كانت هناك مطالبه
من قبل جميع النواب في مجلس العمومي
بمختلف انتماءاتهم الحزبيه بادراج الحرس
الثوري على قائمه همم الارهاب المحظوره في
المملكه المتحده ويجيب تذكير بان عناصر
الحرس الثوري يعني هم تحت عقوبات وفق
التشريعات الحاليه ولكن عند ختان همم يعني
الجلسه التي اشرف عليها في الاخير همم
الوزير
وهو وزير لشؤون اوروبا وايضا مكلف الامور
الامنيه قال بان لا جديده على وضع همم
يعني علي رضا اكبر ذو الجنسيه البريطانيه
المزدوجه الايرانيه البريطانيه قال لم
تكون هناك اي يعني همم اخبار جديده بخصوص
اصدار همم قرار اعدامه بسبب بسبب تعامله
او تورطه في مواضيع تجسس وفقه الادعاءات
الايرانيه انه كان همم يتجسس لصالح
الاستخبارات الخارجيه البريطانيه ولكن همم
كان هناك يعني تمديد وشجر لهذا القرار من
قبل وزاره الخارجيه تم اصدار همم بيان امس
واليوم تم التاكيد على انه هناك اتصالات
مع مع
السفير البريطاني في طيران او همم التواصل
مع الممثل الدبلوماسي الايراني هنا في
المملكه المتحده تم استدعائه مقر همم
وزاره الخارجيه حيث اقف من قبل وزير مكلف
بشؤون الشرق الاوسط اللورد احمد للتمديد
بهذا القرار وايضا مطالبته بالافراج عنه
ولكن يبدو ان
الحكومه الان تريد ان تتوصل الى الطريقه
ما لمحاوله الافراج عن لكن نعرف بان
الاساليب التي يتبعها النظام الايراني على
همم على سنوات يتم استخدام همم ذوي
الجنسيه المزدوجه همم بطاقه ضغط على
الحكومات الغربيه مثل مشاهدنا سواء
بالنسبه لبريطانيا او بالنسبه لفرنسا
والولايات المتحده وبالتالي
التي يمكن ان تقوم بها اذا لم تلتزم همم
طهران بما تريده او تطالب به لندن الان
همم ما الذي يجمع عليه المحللون
والمراقبون همم فيما يتعلق بالاجراءات
التي باستطاعه بمقدور لندن ان تتخذها ان
كان لتضغط او عقابا ان نفذ الاعدام
يعني من خلال الكلمه الختاميه لا النائب
بوب بلاك مان الذي يعني ااه خصص هذه الجسد
لمده ثلاث ساعات وكان هو ايضا من بين
الحاضرين في مؤتمر المعارضه الايرانيه في
فرنسا في صيف 2018
نتذكر ونعرف بان
الحرس الثوري كان يريد ان يفجر هذا هذا
المؤتمر وتم القبض على ديبلوماسي همم
ايراني كان يعمل همم اسد الله اسديه يعمل
في الجنه وتم الحكم عليه بتورته في محاوله
تفجير هذا المؤتمر الذي كان يحضره جنسيات
مختلفه وسياسيين من مختلف العالم في هذا
المؤتمر الضخم هو الان حكم عليه ب20 سنه
في بلجيكا ويبدو هنا قلق خلال كلمه
الختاميه بانه يريد ان تضغط الحكومه
البريطانيه على نادره الب حتى لا يكون
هناك تبادل همم تبادل السجناء بين طهران
وبين همم بروكسل يجب التذكير بان يعني
التوقيع على مذكره تفاهم بين البلدين
لتبادل السجناء وبالتالي هنا قلق كبير
وتريد يعني على الاقل من الجانب النواب ان
ان تكون الحكومه سباقه للضغط على الجانب
البلجيكي حتى لا يتم يعني اخذ بعين
الاعتبار يعني هذا التبادل وربما وربما
ستظهر ايران بانها ربما كسبت الرهان وتقول
بانها انتصرت في هذا الصراع بين الجانبين
وبالتالي هناك ضغوطات على همم البلجيكي
ولكن بالنسبه لبريطانيا هناك محاولات
الان- التنسيق مع الشركاء الدوليين في
محاوله يعني المزيد من الاجراءات
الاعقابيه وايضا يعني كان هناك يعني
انتقاد كبير للخطه الشامله لكبح جماح همم
ال- الانشطه النوويه الايرانيه عام 2015
التي منحت التي منحت ايران اكثر من 100
مليار اا يعني الدولار
للجانب الايراني بعد توقيع هذه الاتفاقيه
وهذا ما انتقده النواب اليوم الرساله
وافيه شكرا جزيلا لك مصطفى زارو مراسل
العربيه من لندن تحياتنا اليك شكرا
نبقى في ايران ولكن نشير الى انه الوثائق
السريه وفقا لمحامي بايدا وضعت في غير
مكانها عن غير قصد لنا عوده لهذا الموضوع
بعد قليل ولكن في ملف ايراني اخر وهو
الموازنه ففي الوقت الذي يحتاج فيه الشارع
على الاوضاع المترديه تخرج الموازنه
الايرانيه دون ان تراعي المطالب الاساسيه
اموالهم ضخمه يا طاهر رصدها النظام
لمؤسساته الامنيه والدينيه بما لا يتمشى
مع الوضعين الانساني والاقتصاديه
المترديين في البلاد فمثلا موازنه هذا
العام تزيد على خمسه الاف ومئتين مليار
اذا خمسه الاف يعني تتحدث عن خمسه
مليار تومان خصص منها النظام بلخصص منها
قرابه
120,000 مليار لميزانيات الحرس الثوري
بزياده مقدره بثمانيه وعشرين في المئه
ايضا فقد رصدت زياده في ميزانيته بالنسبه
36%
وللشرطه زياده بنسبه 44% كما تم رفعه
ميزانيه المخابرات والسجون بمقدار النصف
عند هذا الحد بل طالت مؤسسات الدعايه
والاعلام كمؤسسه الاذاعه والتلفزيون اذا
استفادت من زياده بلغت 42% ولا تقتصر
الدعايه على الاعلام واحتفل النظام نظام
الايراني منابر اخرى مثل
الحوزات على هذا رصد لحوزات قم وحدها فقط
حوالي تسعه الاف مليار تومانا
من المؤسسات استفادت ميزانيه ضريح الخميني
مثلا من زياده ما نسبته 71% ومثل هذه
الزيادات ضخمه في ميزانيات المؤسسات ساعه
النظام لتمريرها عبر الدفع بزيادات في
رواتب الموظفين وان كانت بالنسبه لا
تتجاوز 20 في المئه دائما ما تسجل الحكومه
عجزا بمقدار ثلاث مثل ما حدث في السنوات
الاخيره ما ادى الى ذروه الدين الحكوميه
ونمو التضخم الذي بلغ اربعين في المئه
ساقت الحكومه مبررات مبنيه على توقعات غير
مضبوطات تفيد بان مداخلها سترتفع من
عائدات تصدير النفط والايرادات الضريبيه
[موسيقى]
اعتبر رئيس النظام السوري بشار الاسد ان
اللقاءات السوريه التركيه برعايه روسيا
يجب ان تكون مبنيه على انهاء التواجد
العسكري التركي في الاراضي السوريه كي
تكون مثمره في اول تعليق له على التقارب
بين الدولتين بعد قطيعه استمرت 11 عاما
من جهتي هنا فوازير الخارجيه التركيه
مولود وامكانيه لقائه بوزير الخارجيه
السوريه الاسبوع المقبل مؤكدا ان العمل
جار على تحديد موعد واضاف انه يمكن اجراء
اللقاء او الى فبراير القادم
ثلاثه ضباط بينهم ضابط برتبه لواء في قوه
النظام برفع عفرين شمال غرب حلب المرصد
وقال ان القوات التركيه استهدفت مواقع
قوات النظام في قريه مياسه الخاضعه لسيطره
القوات الكرديه
[موسيقى]
وصلت وزيره خارجيه فرنسا والمانيا الى
اديس ابابا في مهمه دعم الاتفاق السلام
الذي ابرم العام الماضي مع مقاتلي جامعه
اقليم تيجرايل لانهاء الحرب
بدا تسليم الثقيله تنفيذا لاحد البنود
الرئيسيه اتفاق السلام الموقعي في نوفمبر
بين الحكومه
بعد جولاتي تفوضيه مضنيه قام فيها الاتحاد
الافريقي بالدوري الابرص سلمت الجبهه
الشعبيه لتحرير التراي اسلحتها الثقيله في
منطقه ابو لعب القرب من مدينه مقالي حاضره
اقليم تنفيذا لاحد البنود الرئيسيه في
اتفاق السلام المبرم بين اطراف الصراع
الاثيوبي بجنوب افريقيا في نوفمبر الماضي
هذه الخطوه اعتبرها البعض بدايه مبشره
وفصلا جديدا للواقع العسكري بالاقليم
ونهايه حوار البندقيه فيما يرى مراقبون
اخرون ان تنفيذ اتفاقيه السلام كافه وبسطه
تنميه في المناطق التي شهدت الصراعات هي
الضامن لاخماد نيران الحرب واقرار السلام
وبين متفائلين ومشكك يخفي المشهد السياسي
الحالي سنوات عجافا من الحرب الضروس التي
اودت بحياه مئات الالاف خلال اقل من سنتين
كما شردت الملايين من سكان البلاد
السؤال الذي توجهنا به هل تعتقد ان تسليم
جبهه تجراى لسلاحها سيضع نهايه تامه
المجاوره قد تضررت جراء الحرب في الفتره
الماضيه تسليم الاسلحه الثقيله لوحده ليس
كافيا يجب ايضا تكثيف الجهود لايصال
المساعدات الانسانيه اللازمه للمتضررين
اليوم
الاسلحه الثقيله وهذه خطوه مباشره في
تحقيق السلام ويجب ان تشكر الجبهته على
التزامها بتنفيذ الاتفاقيه والوفاء بوعدها
حاليا امر يجيب تشجيعه لتحقيق السلام فقد
التزمت الحكومه الفدراليه وجبهه تحرير
بتنفي عليه يجب ارجاعه الخدمات الاساسيه
لاقليم ولا يجب للشعب ان يعاني اكثر
[موسيقى]
نجح اهالي ضحايا انفجار المرفق في بيروت
بالضغط لمنع انعقاد مجلس القضاء الاعلى
والذي كان على وشك تعيين قاض رديف للقاضي
طارق البيطار وقد تم تحديد يوم الاثنين
المقبل كم موعد لاستدعاء الاهالي الذين
شاركوا في عشق الحجاره على قصر العدل
والتحقيق معهم
[موسيقى]
صوره يحملها والدها بحث عن عداله لبنه
فقدها في انفجار مرفع بيروت وبعد ان طالبه
اكثر من عامين باستجواب المتهمين فتى هو
متهم بالمشاركه باعمال
شهدها محيطه قصر العدل
هو واحد من تسعه من اهالي الضحايا تم
استدعائهم للتحقيق
ضحاياكم
الدين
قلبي علمتها لما تروح الانفجار
الضحايا للوقوفي بالمرصاد لمحاولات
التعليم نظيف للقاضي طارق
جلسه مجلس القضاء الاعلى لكن الخوف يتمنى
لكم الاهالي من محاولات السلطه المستمره
لشله تحقيقات في ذلك تستمر محاولاتهم
لتدويل قضيتهم في قضيه
بريطانيا ملكه
[موسيقى]
فات من قاضي لحتى ينحط قاضي اخر محله هذا
بيسمح مجله تدخلات السياسيه يا اللي اكيد
هاي ضحايا هن الضده في قاضي مستلم هذا
الملف بيقدري يرجع على شغله صار له سنه
ممنوع عن العمل هناك حلول لايعته الى
العمل غير تعيين قاضي بديل لا ينفي بعض
الاهالي تواصلهم مع القاضي الفرنسي الذي
سيصل نهايه الشهر الى بيروت لعل زيارته
تعيد العدل الى ساحه الجريمه لم تعمل
السلطه اللبنانيه على تجميد تحقيقات
انفجار المرفق لمنع استجواب المتورطين فقط
بل حاولت الضحيه الى جلاد وبات الاهالي هم
المطالبون اليوم بالتوجه الى غرف
التحقيقات غنوا يتيم العربيه بيروت
تتابعون معنا ايضا في العربيات 360 في
شوارع كياف تحت الصور مدى كره الكريمير
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد
بينهما اختلافات جذريه في الاراء
والايديولوجيات فالاول وديمقراطيون والاخر
وجوهري لكن خطا الاحتفاظ بالوفاء السريه
جمعهما البيت الابيض بعد انتظار طويل
للتوضيح اقر اخيرا بالعثور على وثائق
سريعه تعود الى الفتره التي كان يتولى
فيها الرئيس
منصبا نائب الرئيس في حديد باراك اوباما
اين تحدث بين 2009 و2017 البيت الابيض قال
انه عثر على عدد صغير من الوفاء السريه في
منزل الخاص في االمتون في ولايه زلار كما
عثر على وثائق اخرى مصنفه سريعه في مركز
بحوث في واشنطن حيث كان يملك بيضا
لكنه بايضا نفى في وقت سابق علمه بمحتوى
الوثائق مشيرا الى انه حاله ما اكتشف
محامه ان بعض هذه الوفاء كان سريا اتصلوا
بهيئه المحفوظات لتسليمها اياها واعرب عن
استعداده التام للتعاون مع الجهات المعنيه
والمعلومات السريه على محمل الجده عندما
كان المحامون يفرغون مكتبي في جامعه
بنسلفانيا
في الكابيتول عندما عملت لمده اربع سنوات
وكنت نائبا لرئيس ووجدوا بعض المستندات في
صندوق كما تعلم في خزانه مغلقه او على
الاقل مقفله وبمجرد ان فعلوا ذلك ادركوا
ان هناك العديد من المستندات السريه في
ذلك الصندوق وفعلوا ما كان ينبغي عليهم
فعله واقام على الفور بالاتصال بهيئه
المحفوظات لتسليها
عاصفه انتقادات اثيرت بعد العثور على
التلك الوثائق السريه في عهده بايدي لكنها
لم تكن من الجمهوريين وحدهم بحسب صحيفه
وسط الجنينل لكن من انصار بايضن
الديمقراطيه ايضا حيث دعوا الى اجراء
تحقيقات لمعرفه كيف تم الاحتفاظ بهذه
الوثائق السريه في مركز ابحاث بايدن الذي
يرتاده طلاب ويمكن ان يدخله اي شخص اخر
وبالفعل اعلنت وزاره العدل تعيين مدعي عام
مستقل لتحقيق في هذه القضيه وبحسب ووصف
فان اكتشاف الوفاق سيزيد الضغط السياسي
على بايد خاصه بعد تحقيقات لوزاره العدل
في قضيه مشابهه تتحدث عن الرئيس السابق
دونالد ترامب وبعد حصول الجمهوريين على
اغلبيه المقاعد في مجلس النواب الامريكي
وتولي كفن مقار في رئاسه المجلس ستصبح
ملاحقه الجمهوريين حتمياتا اكد على بعدها
تاكيد الباقي الابيض بوجود الوفاق اكد
ضروره التحقيق مع بيضين بشيانها
[موسيقى]
الوثائق السريه التي عثر عليها في منزل
ومكتب الرئيس هو شخص بقي في الحكومه لاكثر
من 40 عاما هذا الشخص كان حريصا جدا على
النظر بامر وثائق الرئيس ترامب والان نجد
انه عندما كان نائبا للرئيس احتفظ بالعديد
من الوثائق السريه باماكن مختلفه
يبدو ان مسلسل الوثائق السريه سيسيطر على
الاخبار بالايام القادمه في الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه يطهر
الى فلوريدا حيث مارا لاجو مقر اقامه
الرئيس السابق دونالد ترامب عثر في اغسطس
الماضي على وثائق سريه الى درجه ان موظفي
مكافحه التجسس التابعين لمكتب التحقيقات
الفيدرالي ومحامي وزاره العدل يحتاجوا الى
تصاريح اضافيه قبل ان يسمح لهم الاطلاع
على وثائق محدده وعثر في الصناديق ال 15
التي سلمها ترامب على مئه
واربعه او اربع 84 وثيقه تحمل عباره سريه
او سريه للغايه رغم مغادره ترامب في البيت
الابيض في 20 21 صحيفه واشنطن بوست كشفت
حين ذلك عن ان احدى الوثائق السريه اذا
انكشفت حين ذلك عن ان احد هذه الوثائق
التي صدرها الاف بي اي تتضمن اصفا للقدرات
النوويه والدفاعات العسكريه لقوه اجنبيه
وقالت الصحيفه ان بعض الوثائق التي عثر
عليها في مقر اقامه ترامب في مراغو كانت
سريه جدا الى درجه ان الرئيس ومسؤولي
الحكومه او من هم في مستوى قريب لذلك يسمح
لهم بتفويض مسؤولين حكوميين اخرين
السريه وضعت الاداره الامريكيه في موقف
حرج ومع التطورات التي تظهر تباعا يتوقع
ان تستمر القضيه في اثاره الضجه وقد يتبين
انها تعرقل تحقيقا حول وثائق ترامب ويرى
محللون ان هذه القضيه قد تدخل في اعتبارات
سياسيه حساسه قد تدخل ذلك في التحقيق
المرتبط بترامب الذي دعا فورا استغل ذلك
الى ان يخضع بيضا للتحقيق بنفسه وتسائل
متى سيدهم الاف بي اي مقرات جو بايدن
الكثيره او حتى البيت الابيض وطرحت صحيفه
في ما قال لراي سبب اثاره الضجه حول وثائق
ترامب قبل فتره قليله من الانتخابات
النصفيه للتشكيك في نزاهه الجمهوريين
واساءه استخدامهم للسلطه ودفعت واشنطن
بوست بان وثائق بايدين عثر عليها في
الثاني من نوفمبر قبل اسبوع من الانتخابات
الا ان الكشف عنها كان قبل ايام فقط
والاكيد الان ان ترامب سيسعى للاستفاده من
الموقف بعد تورط بايدي في ازمه مماثله
ريد تسليما
اكتشاف الوثائق السريه في مكتب الرئيس
اعتمر في الاوساط السياسيه اجبر هديه قد
يحصل عليها الرئيس دونالد ترامب الذي دعى
مكتب التحقيقات الفيدرالي الى مداهمه منزل
بايدن كما فعل في مقر اقامته في مرغو في
اغسطس الماضي زاعما في الوقت نفسه ان
السلطات لن تضطهد بعيدا بالطريقه التي
تعرضه نفسه لها الامر الذي يخدم ما يروج
له ترامب لدى جمهوره من المحافظين او ما
يعرف بالماجا بانه يتعرض لمعايره مزدوجه
في التعامل لكن السؤال يبقى اذا ما كانت
هذه السياسه التي يتبعها ترامب والتي نجح
فيها لفتره طويله اذا ما كان لها تاثير
على الحزب الجمهوري وعلى المحافظين داخل
الحزب واذا ما كانت كفيله باستعاده نفوذ
ترامب داخل الحزب الجمهوري النفوذ الذين
راينا افوله خلال الانتخابات المطالبه
لرئيس مجلس النواب في الكونغرس والارتفاع
بها كافه في الجوله الخامسه عشر
الجمهوريين في مجلس النواب الى الالتفاف
حول ممثل كاليفورنيا لكن تم تحديه علنا من
قبل بعض مؤيديه الاكثر ولاا بما في ذلك
لورين بوبرد وامات جيتس
[موسيقى]
من واشنط ناديه البلبيسي مراسله العربيه
اهلا بك معنا ناديه اخر ما سمعناه عن
محامي يقول انه الوثائق وضعت في غير
مكانها المناسب عن غير قصد فيما مكارثي
يدعو طبعا اليوم الى يعني فتح تحقيق في
هذا الموضوع الى مساء
القضيه تاخذ مسارها نحو المساءله نحو
التحقيق هذا ما تبديه كل المؤشرات
دون ادنى شك طاهر والفوضى التي تحدثت عنها
ربما ستبدا بعد قليل او الضجه المصاحبه
لهذه المعلومات حيث سيكون هناك مؤتمر
للمتحدثه باسم البيت الابيض كريم جانكير
بعد دقائق تاكد بان كل الاسئله الصحفيين
ستتمحور حول الاتهامات للبيت الابيض بعدم
الشفافيه وخصوصا ونحن سمعنا قبل قليل من
مرج غالن وزير العدل الذي قال انه سيعين
محقق خاص للبحث والتحقيق اذا كان هناك
ارتكاب لجريمه ما بالنسبه لهذه الوثائق
وهذا مصطلح يستخدم من قبل وزاره العدل
بالفعل البيت الابيض اولا قال بانه اكتشف
هذه الوثائق الاولى التي تقدر عددها
بحوالي 10 وتحدث لنا عنها وقال بان الرئيس
نفسه بانه كان ربما عن طريق الخطا وكان في
خزانه ما في مكتب الذي تحدث عنه قبل قليل
لكن لم في البيت الابيض كان يعرف تماما
بان كان هناك وثائق اخرى همم كشف عنها
ليله امس فقط رغم ان كريم جون بير سؤلت
اكثر من مره
ودوما تحيل كل هذه الاسئله الى وزاره
العدل لكن البيت الابيض محاصره الان
الرئيس الذي قال منذ اليوم الاول بانه اهم
همم اولويات هذه الاداره هو الشفافيه هو
الكشف عن اي خطا يمكن ان يرتكب الان يبدو
وكانه يتستر على هذه المعلومات وبالتالي
على الرئيس
ان يجيبه على هذه الاسئله لماذا يخفي
البيت الابيض هذه المعلومات وخصوصا وان
الوثائق الاولى كانت قبل ايام من
الانتخابات النصفيه في الكونغرس ناديه
يعني هناك اتهامات من قبل الجمهوريين ل-
اا وزاره العدل الامريكيه بازدواجيه
المعايير والتسييس في هذه القضيه لصالح
الرئيس الحالي على ماذا يعتمد الجمهوريون
في هذا
ما هي يعني الدلائل او النقاط التي
يعتمدون عليها
طبعا الجمهوريين كانوا يقولون والرئيس
عفوا ترامب نفسه كان يقول بان وزاره العدل
مسيسه وبانها تحاول ان تثبت بان الرئيس
ترامب كان متورط باخفاء هذه الوثائق لكن
وزاره العدل كما تعرفين هي اداره
ديمقراطيه وزير العدل نفسه معين من قبل
الرئيس بيدن ومن هنا جاء هذا الاتهام
البعض يراه بانه اتهام حزبي ليس اكثر وحرص
مرقه اليوم على ان يعين هذا المحقق خاص
حتى يبعد عن نفسه هذه الصفه وهي عدم
النزاهه فقط لانه ديموقراطي ومعين من قبل
الرئيس وبالتالي يقول بانني ستعامل بنفس
المعايير بالنسبه للرئيس السابق والرئيس
الحالي ولذا قام بتعيين قادم مدعي عامين
هو الرئيس ترامب حتى لا يقال بانه
ديموقراطي
وسيخفي بعض الحقائق لكن بشكل عام كما
تعرفين همم راويه الجمهوريون بداوا
يتحدثون عن لجنه خاصه فقط فقط في هذه
الوثائق السريع اصلا كانوا هم يعدون ملفات
كبيره للرئيس بايدن من الخروج الفوضى ومن
افغانستان موضوع ابنه هانتربايدن علاقته
بالصين وغيره الان قدم لهم هذه الملفات
على طبق من ذهب وبالتالي ربما سنرى مره
اخرى همم سيناريو معكوس لما رايناه
بالسنوات السابقه كان ضد الرئيس ترامب
الان ضد الرئيس
الان من الجمهوريين وبالتالي هذا يثير
ربما السؤال اكبر اذا بالفعل تفاعل هذا
الموضوع عن صلاحيه الرئيس لقياده الحزب
الديمقراطيس باختصار جدد انه يصير فيها
تحقيقه مساءله من حيث التداعيات القانونيه
والقضائيه
اوعى اكيد يعني لماذا الرئيس لم يكن يدرك
بان هذه الوثائق لا يستطيع ان يحملها خارج
البيت الابيض بمجرد خروجه يعني مثلا لم
نسمع ان الرئيس بوش او الرئيس اوباما مثلا
قاموا باخذ وثائق رغم ان هذا يعني من
البديهيات ومن المحظورات على اي رئيس على
اي نائب رئيس يعمل بالبيت الابيض الوثائق
تصنف بانها كلاسيفايد اي سريه وبالتالي
حتى لو لم تكن سريه بالمفهوم الذي نعرفه
يعني لكن هي تابعه للدوله وبالتالي بمجرد
خروجه يجب ان يسلمها الى السجل الوطني
بين الملفات اخرى هو الاكثر تابعات
وتداعيات على الرئيس وعلى سمعته وعلى
ادارته اذا ما صار فيه مسائله او موضوع
افغانستان او ملفات اخرى
هذا اسهل ملف بالنسبه للجمهوريه وبالتالي
سهل جدا شحن الراي العام ضد الرئيس وايضا
ربما تسييس الملف واعطاه اكثر من اللازم
وبالتالي جر اسم الرئيس بالوحل وهذا كافي
ربما الديمقراطيه ليتحدوه على قياده
للولايه الثانيه شكرا جزيلا لك ناديه قلب
البيسي مراسله العربيه وحول نفس الموضوع
ينضم الينا من واشنطن الدكتور ادمون غريبه
الاستاذ في العلاقات الدوليه اهلا بك
دكتور
حول التعامل وزاره العدل الامريكيه مع
قاديتي وثائق ترامب وبايجن كيف ستتعامل
الوزاره مع ازمه المقارنه بين القريتين مع
العلم بان هناك نقطه تحسب لترامب بانه
الوفاء وقت ما يعني همم
استصدارها والحصول عليها كان وقتها ترامب
هو رئيس للولايات المتحده الامريكيه وهو
الشخص الوحيد بالولايات المتحده الذي
يمتلك حق رفع السريه ولكن بايضا كان نائبا
للرئيس وهي نقطه لصالح ترامب
في الولايات المتحده واعتقد ان المدعيين
العامين الذين تم تعيينهم للتحقيق في كل
من قضيه ترامب
وما شخصين مختلفين وهنا نتحدث عن المدعي
العامين فانا التحدي سيكون كيف سيتعامل كل
من هؤلاء
قضيه الرئيس
هل سنرى ازدواجيه في المعايير وهذا ما
يتفهم
الجمهوريون يوجهوا تهم للديمقراطيين بانهم
يستخدموا نغير مزدوجه لانه تم اكتشاف هذه
الوفاء في اثنين نوفمبر قبل الانتخابات
بعده ايام ورغم ذلك
فانه لم يعلن عنها للراي العام لانه كان
بالتاكيد ستؤثر على النتائج التصويت في
الانتخابات النصفيه وبالتالي فان تم اخفاء
ذلك ومؤخرا في اليومين يعني انت برز
الحديد عن اكتشاف وثائق جديده هذه الوثائق
ايضا ستثير الكثير من الاسئله هل كان
الرئيس يعلم هو يقول انه لم يكن يعلم بها
همم وانها موجوده واذا كان يعلم هذه مشكله
ايضا دكتور بس استفيد من وجودك معنا
لاسالك الى اي مدى تعتقد بانه اثاره هذه
القضيه ستؤثر همم ايجابا بالنسبه الى ما
يريده ترامب على قضيته هو بمعنى انه
ديمقراطيين بتراجعوا قليلا في الملف لكي
يخفف عن انفسهم في ملف بيضه
بدون شكر رئيس ترامب الرئيس السابق طبعا
الاستبهاده من هذا الموضوع سيستغله ويقول
بانه كان هناك ازدواجيا للمعايير انظروا
كيف يتعاملوا يتعاملوا معي بطريقه
اخرى ولكن القضيه
مجلس النواب سيبدا بالتحقيق ليس فقط في
هذه القضيه
دفع الضرائب من قبل وابنه وقضيه علاقه
بالرئيس خاصه عندما اقام علاقات اقتصاديه
مع شركه اوكرانيا وشركات صينيه اعذرني
اكتفي معك بهذا القدر دكتور اسمه استاذ في
العلاقات الدوليه شكرا جزيلا لك بنعوضها
مره ثانيه ان شاء الله ههه شكرا جزيلا
[موسيقى]
البنتاجون يقول الان ان التغيير الذي تمت
في القياده العسكريه الروسيه في اوكرانيا
يعكس التحديات المنهجيه في
ما يسمى البنت الروسي الى صوره اليوم الى
تصريح اليوم في العربيه 360
على شكل طابع بريد يحمل صوره الكرملين
يحترق الامر الذي جذب الاوكرانيين
ولا تحتاج الصوره راويه الى الكثير من
التعليق نكتفي بها
الصوره اليوم لتصريح ولا فيديو اجا وقت
صهيب
طبعا جاء وقت اخبار الساعه يعني متاخرين
25 ثانيه ولكن على حسابكم
شكرا شكرا
[موسيقى]